Roll up, roll up, come one and all!
The circus is in town!
And not just any circus: the greatest show
in all the multiverse!
Don't pay attention to the fact that the tents
weren't here yesterday, or that you don't
remember hearing anything about it before
now.
That's just the circus magic at work, and
there's no circus more magical or more mysterious
than Herman Fuller's Circus of the Disquieting!
It’s a show so marvelous that even the SCP
Foundation wants to get in on the act!
So come watch the show, come feel the magic!
After all… what do you have to lose?
The story of this humble traveling show begins
in 1893, with the founder, Herman S. Fuller.
He was born into a wealthy family, and at
the age of 21, he was invited by his uncle
to Chicago to see the buildings his company
had constructed for the world's fair.
He was dazzled by the sights he saw in the
windy city, and from then on he dedicated
his life to finding a way to bring that same
awe to people across America, and eventually,
the world.
After receiving a small loan from his uncle,
Herman Fuller set about building the miraculous
circus you see before you today!
He knew he had to get a leg up over his competitors
- after all, the 1890's were a golden age
for traveling shows in America.
So, Herman devoted his time to research, trying
to find acts and oddities that were truly
out of this world.
He learned the way between worlds, stole books
from the Wanderer's Library, and with them
studied alchemy, transmutation, sarkism, and
other supernatural disciplines.
That real magic and touch of the macabre would
be what made Herman Fuller's Circus of the
Disquieting so special, and would ultimately
give it its longevity.
Herman Fuller's first anomalous acquisition
was a genuine Fiji Mermaid, like the one that
famed showman P.T.
Barnum kept on display around the same time
period.
Unlike Barnum's, however, Fuller's mermaid
had been brought to life.
The crowds loved it, but like all attractions,
pretty soon crowds grew bored of it and hungered
for the next strange sight, so Fuller went
about acquiring more curiosities.
His next important acquisition was the man
with the upside-down face, or 'Manny' for
short.
He serves as second-in-command to the ringmaster,
and manages things behind the scenes, including
the acquisition of new talent.
Many other anomalous beings and items were
purchased for the circus by Fuller through
the auction company known as Marshall, Carter
and Dark - another group that the SCP Foundation
makes a habit of keeping tabs on.
Another thing that sets this circus apart
from any other is the clowns, because they
aren’t like any you’ve ever seen before!
Though Herman Fuller's Circus of the Disquieting
employs professional clowns, the vast majority
of the Clown troupe are non-human, descendants
of an extradimensional race of magical shapeshifters.
Nobody really knows why they decided to come
to our reality and help Herman Fuller set
up his circus, but the leading theory is simply
that they were bored.
These original Clowns are the progenitors
of the “turned Clowns” and the “bred
Clowns” - turned Clowns being humans who
underwent a Clown transformation procedure,
and the bred Clowns being artificially-grown
children produced by the other two types.
Earlier in the circus' history, before we
knew what we know today about genetics, much
more barbaric methods were used to create
new clowns - young human subjects would be
subjected to beatings and painful transfigurations
at the hands of the circus' Child-Breaker.
These days, however, the circus no longer
employs a Child-Breaker.
Instead, the creation of new Clowns is the
responsibility of resident Clown Breeder,
Richard C. Normous.
And before you say anything, don't laugh,
that is his real name.
Some of the most famous Clowns in the troupe
are Eugene and Pius both of which are original
Clowns, Mr. Noodles who is a bred Clown, and
Icky the troupe leader who was once a human
with magical abilities known as Veronica Mason.
She still possesses her anomalous powers as
Icky, and her magic act is one of the most
beloved parts of our show.
After the sudden disappearance of Herman Fuller,
Icky inherited his position as ringmaster,
and has been doing a spectacular job ever
since.
Not every attempt to create new Clowns has
been as successful as Icky and Mr. Noodles
though.
Some of the earlier attempts were quite grotesque
to look at.
Herman Fuller's troupe of Clowns are an enthusiastic,
happy-go-lucky, but occasionally violent bunch,
capable of minor feats of reality-bending
that allow them to perform all manner of tricks.
They live on a diet of mostly sugar, and need
to be milked regularly.
Clown Milk is an invaluable substance here
at the circus, as it's the secret ingredient
of the famous black cotton candy - which,
by the way, is free with admission.
It causes the brain to produce high levels
of serotonin, meaning that when you eat it,
you're primed to have a great time.
Be careful, though - raw, concentrated Clown
Milk is not for human consumption.
Though the Clowns love to drink it, even a
small amount can cause a human to go into
cardiac arrest due to an overload of happiness.
The sound of calliope music also goes a long
way to helping people truly get the most out
of their visit to Herman Fuller's Circus of
the Disquieting.
The calliope is self-playing, and requires
rolls of perforated paper to be loaded into
it so that it can play a variety of pre-programmed
pieces of music.
Each piece produces a different psychological
effect on visitors who have consumed their
cotton candy.
“The Skater's Waltz” will make them accept
whatever they see at the circus, no matter
how weird, as nothing out of the ordinary.
Wonderful for making sure nobody blabs about
their experience to a certain pesky Foundation...
”Officer of the Year” makes them less
likely to perceive an event as unlawful- we
use that one when we suspect the cops are
closing in.
“Hail!
Hail!
The Gang's All Here!” is used to get people
to congregate at the big top for showtime,
and “American Patrol” causes those who
have eaten the cotton candy to seek out those
who haven't, in order to strongly encourage
them to have some.
“What D'Ya Mean You Lost Your Dog?” is
one that gets played after hours, when it's
time to get the clowns ready for milking.
Now that you have an idea of the history and
how things work around the Circus, it’s
time for the tour.
The circus is made up of a series of tents
and trailers, as well as a midway with standard
rides and games that you might find at any
circus.
Outside of the Big Top, where shows are performed
once a day, there's also the Den of Freaks
and the Hall of Humans Extraordinaire.
The Den of Freaks is home to fantastic acts
like Sluggo, and Elisa the Living Head.
Sluggo is a man whose eyes are on stalks,
like those of a slug, and he can bend those
stalks into any shape he wishes.
He can even use them to create the shapes
of human faces!
Elisa the Living Head is a woman whose head
lives independently of her body, which is
safely kept in storage.
Even without her body, she can speak and sing
and often answers questions from the audience.
The Hall of Humans Extraordinaire is home
to performers who lack physical anomalies
but otherwise display otherworldly talents
like The Amazing Zoltan, a fortune-teller
and alchemist who Fuller picked up at a place
called the Utterly Bazaar.
The Hall of Humans Extraordinaire also used
to be home to Icky the Clown, back when she
was still Veronica the magician.
The recent lineup has changed quite a bit,
thanks mainly to the activities of the Circus’s
constant enemy - you guessed it, The SCP Foundation.
Or as they are better known to the stable
of inter-dimensional clowns as the “Miss
Essie P. Foundation”.
The Foundation does not appear to be a fan
of circus folk, and many of the former acts
are now in their containment.
For example, Madame Rezarta and her Amazing
Palm Reader, also known as SCP-1884-A and
SCP-1884-B. Madame Rezarta was a blind Albanian
woman in her 60's who was born without hands.
She shared a psychic link with a creature
named Luana, who was a large, shapeless entity
made up of 932 hands.
929 of these hands appear to be those of an
old woman, and share Madame Rezarta's DNA,
but the remaining 3 hands seem to be from
a male Caucasian adolescent, an adult Hispanic
female, and a Bengal tiger.
Through their psychic link, Luana acted as
Madame Rezarta's eyes, feeling its surroundings
to provide her with a mental map.
Fuller attempted to buy the two of them when
they were 8 years old, but when their parents
refused, he sent Manny to whisk them away
under the cover of darkness.
Madame Rezarta's act involved sending Luana
to feel the faces of audience members and
then trying to describe their appearance based
on what Luana felt.
The act was a hit, but Madame Rezarta claimed
to have been horribly abused during her time
with Herman Fuller.
The two of them escaped while on tour, and
were picked up by old’ Essie P. while trying
to rent a hotel room in the UAE.
Then, there's Virtuoso, also known as SCP-1860.
Virtuoso was once a book of sheet music that
was transfigured by Herman Fuller into one
of the circus' original acts.
It's a tall, thin, humanoid being encased
in a densely woven paper-based material that
stretches like nylon or spandex.
It constantly drips black ink… ink which
it has a telekinetic control over.
It uses the ink to create the shapes of musical
notes, which float around it while it sings.
Virtuoso can sing in multiple voices at once
across different vocal ranges, and constantly
performs arias and showtunes for whoever is
listening.
It was recovered from underneath a burnt-down
shack at a fairground where the circus had
been set up earlier.
In containment, Virtuoso still sings, but
translations from Italian reveal that the
lyrics of the arias it's singing have been
changed to reflect its own situation.
Some of these translated lyrics include- “One
day I'll tell you of my creation, and life
with the circus, born from the ringmaster,
his breed”
Another act the circus dearly misses is Motormouth,
also known as SCP-2094.
He was one of the rare human clowns, born
in New York City in the late 70's.
From birth, he displayed a supernatural level
of flexibility in his lower jaw, and as he
grew older he discovered that he could swallow
large objects and store them in a kind of
pocket dimension until he needed them again.
Unlike Madame Rezarta, he went with Manny
willingly, as even at 8 years old he knew
his alcoholic mother didn't care if he lived
or died.
Motormouth took to the circus like a fish
to water, and grew from a shy child into a
very talented, talkative, and highly charismatic
adult.
He was a juggler, first and foremost, who
would catch pins, balls and knives in his
mouth as part of his routine, but the name
“Motormouth” came later in his career
when he let a stunt driver drive a car off
a ramp and down his throat.
However, as great an act as he was, a conflict
arose between him and Manny over Manny's questionable
methods of sourcing new acts.
Manny found out that Motormouth had been helping
some of the anomalous kids that Manny brought
in get back to their families, and as punishment
for his insubordination, he was locked in
a box and left behind at the end of a Japanese
tour.
The box was marked 'For Essie', because Manny
thought being put in containment was the best
punishment he could think of.
With how strange and unusual its acts are,
and how it always seems to pop in and out
of new locations at strange, unpredictable
times, you might wonder if the Circus has
any sinister motives.
Well, the truth is, though sometimes the acts
can be a little gruesome, their methods of
acquiring new talent a little unorthodox,
and the clowns a little out of control, their
only goal… is to entertain.
In that respect, they’re no better or worse
than any other circus.
So, we hope you've enjoyed your visit.
Make sure to stick around for the show, and
don't forget to take your complimentary serving
of cotton candy.
Because there's nothing quite like a day at
the circus, especially one like Herman Fuller's.
Now check out “SCP Chaos Insurgency Explained”
and “Secret Group That Runs The World - SCP
O5 Council Explained” for more mysterious
groups from the world of the SCP Foundation!